deux heures de vol et pas question de
manquer la pause repas
service de restauration à bord
c'est un excellent service en vol vous
avez même du ketchup
vous avez du ketchup vous avez
hamburgers et des frites
les problèmes s'accumulent dans les
fast-foods russe créée après le départ
de mcdonald's un mois après l'ouverture
des clients se plaignent sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'on leur a servi du pain moisi
ici quelqu'un a trouvé une patte
d'insectes quand ce n'est pas un insecte
entier des soucis d'hygiène mais aussi
d'approvisionnement ils manquent de plus
en plus de frites dans les restaurants
en raison des sanctions occidentales
contre moscou l'enseigne aurait
peut-être dû choisir un autre nom que
délicieux point final
[Musique]
rien
le pays connaît lui aussi une intense
vague de chaleur avec des températures
qui dépassent par endroit les 40 degrés
et pourtant à l'heure où la population
recherche l'ombre et la fraîcheur ses
ouvriers chargés de l'entretien des
routes sont au travail nous profitons de
la température élevée car elle permet à
l'asphalt de se transformer en adhésif
sans dégager de gaz nocifs et puis on va
plus vite pour réparer la route lorsque
l'asphalté colle comme ça si moi je
bouge pas partez vibrations tu fais
remonter l'eau est moi je prends la
place de l'eau l'eau à l'argot en
surface alors si je bouge bien là
descend pas trop vite on est d'accord ça
lui lui de remercier
en fait jusqu'au genou les gens
paniquent pas parce qu'ils ont mis moins
d'une minute à descendre et ils se
disent que naturellement pour en sortir
je met autant de temps j'ai conduit
beaucoup d'hommes politiques connues
voilà près on peut pas dire ils n'en
comptent bien encadré il y en a des
seins panade est pas sympa ce qui semble
cinq parts dans les médias sont souvent
moins sympa et ce qui semble un peu
moins voilà j'en parle parce que
finalement les vtc et j'essaie de c'est
mon métro à moi donc je le prends tous
les jours je sais de quoi je parle quand
hubert est arrivé je le prenais tous les
jours j'étais super content tu y arrives
en costume ah oui pas encore l'habit je
suis désolé qu'ils ouvraient la porte on
avait les bonbons les mangez pas mais
était là quand même les verres d'eau
l'aca s'est énormément dégradé ça veut
dire que le service est tellement
dégradée je suis revenue aux taxis bon
il y en a quand même je dirai pas le nom
mais assez massif vous nous dites y en a
quand même mis à l'eau il y en a quand
même qui était très très bien il est
mort il est mort on peut le dire alors
c'était jacques chirac à il était sympa
ah ouais [ __ ] très sincèrement comme
disait un de mes prédécesseurs
ça m'en touche une sans bouger l'autre
c'était jacques chirac ça a beaucoup
aidé les taxis parce qu'avant c'est vrai
on faisait pareil on a un truc très
parlants 16e et 8e
le 16e 8e l'on comprenait trocadéro
jusqu'à l'avenue montaigne entre toulon
et puis le taxi refusé et refusé en
disant c'est pas assez long c'est pas
assez loin maintenant le taxi
l'acceptent
et maintenant regardons la toute
première image de ce fabuleux télescopes
sur l'écran apparaît un cliché qui
montre des galaxies formées peu après le
big bang il y à 13 milliards d'années
sur la photo les galaxies les plus
lointaines apparaissent sous la forme
d'arc lumineuse résultats de la
déformation de leur lumière par la
distorsion gravitationnelle causée par
la présence d'autres galaxies plus
proches
laissé sans voix et bailly est belle
c'est bon une prouesse technologique qui
fait la fierté du président américain et
ses images vont rappeler au monde que
l'amérique peut faire de grandes choses
puis rappeler au peuple américain en
particulier à nos enfants qu'il n'y rien
en delà de nos capacités
c'est très joli
prénom âge en tout un très long c'est là
ses ipod
c'était en si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec moi vous me contredise est où vous
me contre dit que nous parlions français
tout à l'heure
déjà je ne le ferai jamais
[Musique]
j'ai eu la réponse montre vite non du
coup moi je vais me faire une petite
sieste au ballet op
[Musique]
bonne nuit les amis